FLAMINIA CATTERUCCIA: I'm Flaminia Catteruccia,
an associate professor at the Harvard T.H. Chan School of Public Health.
And today, I'm going to give a lecture on vector biology
and the dynamics of malaria transmission.
The lecture is divided into five chapters.
In the first chapter, I'll talk about the complexity of mosquito biology,
and how that influences malaria transmission.
In the second chapter, I'll look at the journey of the Plasmodium parasites
within the mosquito.
In the third chapter, I'll introduce the concept of vectorial capacity, which
is the interaction of the biological processes that
are important for transmission.
In chapter 4, I'll discuss current methods that
are available for mosquito control.
While in chapter 5, I'll discuss alternative strategies
that might become available in the near future
and might take us to malaria eradication.
Let me start with chapter 1, and describe the complex mosquito biology
and how that influences malaria transmission.
Malaria is transmitted to humans exclusively
by mosquitoes of the Anopheles genus.
There are about 500 Anopheles species in the world.
However, only 30 to 40 are considered important vectors of human malaria.
These species are spread throughout the globe, as seen here in this slide.
And they have very different behaviors during larval and adult stages.
During larval development, which lasts about 7 to 10 days,
mosquito are adapted to very different ecological habitats.
Some mosquito species for instance, prefer
breeding in temporary breeding sites, such as those provided by rain puddles.
While others would prefer breeding in permanent breeding sites, such as rice
fields.
Some mosquitoes are highly adapted to salt water,
and so live in coastal areas.
While other mosquitoes can only survive in fresh water.
These different ecological habitats expose mosquitoes
to different environments.
For instance, different temperature conditions and temperature
shifts between day and night, also different microorganisms, predators,
and nutritional reserves.
In turn, the ecological habitats to which
these mosquitoes are exposed as larvae will
impact the physiology of adults emerging from those breeding sites,
with possible consequences for malaria transmission.
For instance, larvae that are adapted to temporary breeding sites,
might have reduced availability of nutrients
and might have a shorter developmental time.
So the adults emerging from those breeding sites
will generally be smaller in size and might
need to feed more often as adults, on blood, in order
to meet the energetic demands of flying, mating, reproducing, and so on.
This in turn, might create more opportunities for Plasmodium parasites
for their own transmissions, because a mosquito that
bites more often obviously will be more capable of transmitting malaria.
Let's take a look at the mosquito life cycle,
starting from male and female adults emerging from pupa.
After emerging, males and females will have
to find each other in order to mate, so that the female can become inseminated
with sperm transferred by the male.
Then the female will have to go and look for a host for a blood meal.
And after taking a blood meal, she will rest
for a couple of days, during which time she will digest the blood components
and incorporate them into the developing eggs.
After developing the eggs, the female will use the sperm
that she's received by the male to fertilize those eggs.
And then she'll lay them in suitable oviposition sites.
The eggs that are laid will then hatch into larvae.
And the larvae will undergo four developmental stages
before transforming into pupa.
From where then male and female adults will emerge
and the cycle will continue.
Blood feeding is really an essential component in the mosquito life cycle.
And this is a step in which mosquitoes from different species
exhibit quite a variety of behaviors.
For instance, some mosquito species are highly adapted to feeding on humans.
So they are highly anthropophilic.
While other mosquito species predominantly
feed on animals, such as birds, or cows, or rats.
In order to transmit malaria to humans mosquitoes
will have to have a certain degree of anthropophilia,
because they will need to feed on humans at least twice.
The first time they'll have to bite a person that
is infected with malaria parasites and they'll ingest those parasites.
And then after a few days, once sporogonic development is completed,
then that mosquito will inject those parasites into the next human being.
The propensity of a mosquito to feed on humans, rather than animals,
can actually be measured.
And this is the so-called human blood index.
The human blood index can be measured by collecting mosquitoes in the field
and looking at the content of their blood
to see whether it's from animal or from human origin.
This value goes from 0 to 1.
With 0, being mosquitoes that feed exclusively on animals, so highly
zoophilic.
And 1, with mosquitoes that feed only on humans, so highly anthropophilic.
As you can see in this map, there's high indigeneity
among mosquitoes for the human blood index.
And many mosquito species with a high level of anthropophilia
actually cluster in Africa.
And these mosquitoes belong to mosquitoes of the Anopheles gambiae
complex, such as Anopheles gambiae, Anopheles coluzzii.
But also, Anopheles funestus, which is another very important vector
of human malaria in Africa.
Mosquitoes with a high level of anthropophilia
are also found in Papua New Guinea, like Anopheles farauti,
as well as in South America, even if to a lesser extent,
like Anopheles darlingi.
In any given area, there might be multiple Anopheles
species that live in sympatry and this might complicate control measures.
For instance, let's have a look at Africa,
and the Anopheles gambiae complex.
This complex comprises eight mosquito species
that are morphologically identical and can only be
distinguished on the molecular level.
These species include some of the most important malaria vectors,
such as Anopheles gambiae, Anopheles arabiensis, and Anopheles coluzzii.
As well as some more minor vectors, like Anopheles melas and merus,
which are adapted to coastal areas, because they
prefer breathing in salt water.
Also the complex includes some species that
are not considered vectors of human malaria,
such as Anopheles quadriannulatus, because they
tend to bite predominately on animals.
If you look at the major malaria vectors,
Anopheles gambiae and Anopheles coluzzii, these until recently,
were believed to be the same species and just different molecular forms.
Anopheles gambiae was previously known as Anopheles gambiae S form.
While Anopheles coluzzii was previously known as Anopheles gambiae M form.
Anopheles gambiae and Anopheles coluzzii have very similar biting behavior,
because they both tend to feed on humans and late at night and indoors.
However, they show quite different ecological habitats
due to larval developments.
Anopheles gambiae tend to prefer living in temporary breeding sites,
such as rain puddles.
While Anopheles coluzzii prefer living in permanent breeding sites,
such as rice fields.
We don't know yet, whether these two species contribute differently
to malaria transmission.
Anopheles arabiensis is a third important malaria
vector that shares habitats with Anopheles gambiae and Anopheles
coluzzii.
Until recently, this mosquito species was not
considered to be a very important vector for human malaria,
because these mosquitoes also feed on animals, apart from humans,
and so they dilute potential infectious bites.
However, because of their plastic behavior,
and the fact that these mosquitoes can feed outdoors and rest outdoors,
apart from feeding and resting indoors, these mosquitoes
become more difficult to be controlled with current vector control strategies.
And so in recent years, they've become more and more relevant
for malaria transmission.
When multiple mosquito species live in sympatry,
it becomes really difficult to understand the relative contribution
to malaria transmission.
This is well explained in the study by Fontenille et al., conducted in 1997,
in a small village in Senegal, called Dielmo.
What the authors did, they looked at the relative contribution
of three important malaria vectors, Anopheles gambiae,
Anopheles arabiensis, and Anopheles funestus,
over the course of three years.
It is important to note that at that time
Anopheles gambiae were considered to be a single species.
Well, now we know that those species contain both Anopheles gambiae
and Anopheles coluzzii.
What the authors did is they collected mosquitoes from this village
and then they analyzed their salivary glands
to look for the presence of sporozoites of Plasmodium falciparum.
And after this analysis, what they could determine
is that Anopheles gambiae mosquitoes were a very important vector in year
one, while instead the contribution declined in year two,
and was negligible in year three.
While Anopheles arabiensis had almost the opposite pattern.
They were a negligible vector in year one, a little bit more
important in year two, and much more relevant in year three.
While Anopheles funestus had an intermediate pattern.
And they were an important vector in year one, also during the dry season
because these mosquitoes are better adapted to dry conditions,
they disappeared during year two, and they came back strong in year three.
This study is a good example of the complexity of malaria transmission,
even in a small village and prior to any vector control
intervention, as it was back then.
And also shows importance of performing longitudinal studies,
across a number of years, looking at all possible mosquito
species that might be contributing to malaria transmission.